There's the group at the center of major conspiracy theories have been accused
of pulling the strings of major governments around the world for inserting
symbols into such prominent places.
As the US dollar bill and conspiracy theorists have claims that everyone from
the Beatles to Tom Brady to Kanye West are more recent members of the centuries
old society.
There's no doubt the Illuminati have impacted welder fast even if just by being
at the center of conspiracy theories.
But where did this group get it start?
Well,
let's take a look at the man behind the secret society.
Johann Adam.
Why stopped
Johann Adam Weishaupt,
who was born into an academic household in Bavaria.
He came into the world on February the sixth,
17,
48 is the son of a law professor.
When she was only five years old,
his father passed away,
leaving him to be raised by his grandfather.
Also a law professor,
Weiss helps grandfather kept caps,
the Boeing engaged in scholastic activities.
His grandfather was a proponent of the enlightenment movements and the thoughts
and philosophies promoted by enlightenment thinkers,
came to greatly influence Weiss hops during the 17th and 18th century.
Enlightenment movements.
Intellectuals emphasized the importance of reason and individualism over
tradition.
You might also hear the enlightenment referred to as the age of reason among the
movements most famous thinkers with John Locke and Isaac Newton when he was
seven years old.
Ice Helps Education expanded beyond his grandfather's teaching.
The family was Catholic and why sap to began attending a jesuit school.
He was a voracious reader and by the time he was 20 years old,
he has and his doctorate in law.
He began teaching law bars.
Within a year he became the beneficiary of the dissolution of the very religious
order that had educated him.
Political maneuvering coupled with cultural changes made.
The jesuits are a threat to the power of some European leaders,
at least in their eyes.
The order was suppressed in several countries and even the pope issued a brief
suppressing the jesuits because of the order suppression in Seventeen,
73 wise helped was able to move from being a professor of secular law to being a
professor of Canon law at the University of English start before the suppression
only jesuits towards Canon Law now waste,
which could be a professor,
but he nonetheless found himself as the only non clergy member serving.
As such,
although the order has been suppressed,
they still wielded considerable power at the university and Weiss hubs and his
enlightenment influenced ideas well.
We hit some roadblocks as a result,
helped grew to dislike clerics.
He was frustrated and he wanted a way to spread the words of the enlightenment
without being stonewalled by the chair.
Ouch.
So he decided to start his own society about what was the goal of this society.
This is the great object held down by this association as the means of attaining
it is illumination enlightening the understanding by the son of reason which
will dispel the clowns of superstition and prejudice initially why sobs didn't
want to start his own secret society he had wanted to join the free masons,
is a group that he thought would line up nicely with his passion for reason over
religion,
but ultimately he decided that the free masons weren't exactly what he wanted
and so he took the leap and started his own society.
He didn't look to the freemasons for inspiration in rituals and organizational
structure,
though overtime,
especially after I stopped,
ended up joining the freemasons.
The two groups became more linked in the minds of many,
especially conspiracy theorists to start a society.
Why Sampson began reaching out to like minded men.
He had befriended at university,
but they had to be young men.
Anyone over 30 was just too unlikely to be influenced by new ideas and I tapped.
He wanted the men who joined to be true believers in the enlightenment ready to
start spreading the ideals of reason and spreading them as high up as they
could.
The group of men first match in May of 17,
76,
only five of them arrived in the forest that first night carrying torches and
ready to embark on their quest to spread their ideas to the world to be
initiated into the Illuminati.
Why Sally wanted his members to experience being reborn this way,
they would be leaving behind their lives before joining the Illuminati and to be
able to fully immerse themselves in their commitment to the new secret society.
The initiation rights included sacrifices and mystical elements who did men
unknown identities in darkened rooms are hallmarks of such rights.
Games have been made that the Illuminati initiation rights.
I've taken the sacrifice element to its most extreme stage,
the sacrificing of an actual human being to be initiated and reborn.
The idea is that the new member would have to experience death and be reborn and
actually killing someone would give them an insight into the experience of
death,
but the initiation rite is also sent to have given many members the experience
of death and rebirth through the killing of an animal.
The illuminati would put an animal on top of the new member,
kill the animal and just let it bleed to death on top of the new member soaking
in the animal's bloods,
encouraged rebirth and the understanding of life,
death and knowledge overall.
Why Sally did not want the Illuminati to remain just a small academic society
that operated in an echo chamber,
though he wanted it to reach the highest echelons of society with members both
influencing political leaders and even the coming political leaders themselves,
but he also didn't want the society to grow full of men.
He couldn't trust until you weren't truly dedicated to the course.
So the men that mets that first night,
we'd have to be agreed to by the five members present at night as well as prove
themselves to be from families of high standing and wealth.
The latter two requirements would help with myself,
skull to get his ideas moving up the societal ladder and into the minds of
intellectual families and society.
Now,
the order's famous name.
It didn't to ice out right away the first name boy,
his secretive group was the perfect lists,
a name that they actually stuck with for two years.
The idea that a man is perfectible was part of the group's ideals.
Even American founding father Thomas Jefferson appreciated this trait of ice
arts and design ideas,
stating why Sam's seems to be an enthusiastic philanthropist.
He is among those,
as you know,
the excellent Richard price and priestly also are who believe in the indefinite
perfectibility of man.
He thinks he may in time be rendered so perfect that he will be able to govern
itself in every circumstance,
so as to engine none to do well,
the goody can to leave.
Government had no occasion to exercise their powers over him and of course to
render political government useless before the name Illuminati was officially
adopted.
Why?
Sam's also thought about naming the group the be order that's in the Nazi was
ultimately decided upon.
And why Sam's took the owl as the group symbol.
So now you might be wondering,
well,
why did you choose now?
What exactly is the significance of this bird?
Now Minerva,
the goddess of wisdom was accompanied by an owl.
The Owl was away for ways,
helped to indicate the intellectual basis for the secret society while still
keeping its symbolism just to be coded.
The new name was a callback to the occult beliefs within the Spanish culture
during medieval times,
alchemists and magicians were believed to be imbued with a light that signified
the presence of a higher power within within the society.
The members took nicknames.
Why?
Subs as the head of the order was spartacus,
while other adopted names from members included,
a Jackson Tiberius in 17,
77.
Why's helped found a new avenue for recruiting.
He was accepted into a free masons group in Germany and use their society as a
place to find well connected society.
Men who were already acquainted with and interested in secret societies.
The men who were welcomed in were told the following.
Should you see might power false honor excess seek vote.
We would work for you to provide your temporal advantages.
We will bring you as close to the throne as you wish and then turn you over to
the consequences of your folly,
but our inner sanctuary remains closed to such,
which who do you want to learn?
Wisdom wants to learn to make mankind's more clever,
better free and happy,
then be thrice welcomed by us.
The men who joined new found order found themselves a part of a group that was
split into distinct levels as much as waste helped refine the principles of
rationalism and individualism related to the enlightenment movements,
the men who were a part of his fault,
where restrictors in their knowledge about what was going on within their own
organization.
The illuminati had a hierarchy within the structure and the members at the
bottom reported to those.
At the top there were three ranks of men,
novice minerval and illuminated minerval eliminate them interval where at the
top of the Illuminati is pecking order than I am inspired by the Roman goddess
of wisdom.
They spied on each other and on the political and economic goings on in society.
Bringing news back to the order and to helping the Illuminati move forward and
its goals of influencing the top tiers of society.
Do you realize sufficiently what it means to rule to rule in a secret society,
not only over the lesser or more importance of the populace,
but over the best of men over men of all ranks,
nations and religions to rule without external force to unite them in
dishonorably to breathe one spirit and soul into them.
Men distributed over all parts of the world in his first year,
so they'll even ask.
It didn't grow by leaps and bounds.
Initially,
they found only a few dozen interested in qualified men to join.
They know that it's just 60 by 78 80,
but that year,
why stopped added amendment to the Illuminati who proved himself to be
especially helpful in gaining new members and he also attracted a new level of
respect for the secret society and this new member.
He came from.
Why Sampson recruiting grounds in the freemasons,
baron adult Conega had been a member of the freemasons,
but he had risen as far as he could go within their ranks.
So when he heard of y soft and his new smaller group,
he saw an opportunity to have real sway over what was going on in the
organization.
He also likes the Illuminati is relationship with mysticism and forming the
order why Sam's had relied in part on mystic texts.
He read the mysteries of the seven sages of Memphis and the Kabbalah and the two
tanks.
It's made an impact on how he viewed the world around him.
Baron Canoga was also a students of such ideas and liked that why salvage
brought their influence into the Illuminati when he joined gonna get eagerly
read the texts required of new members,
most consistent of works that were banned in the conservative Catholic Bavaria.
In fact,
contigo read the text so quickly that we had to stall for time.
He didn't want can I get to reach the illuminated minerva level so quickly?
So he put off Grenada.
Well,
he tried to come up with new ideas for readings and required actions,
but kinda figured out that y sub two is trying to delay his achievements of the
highest level when he brought this up to wise,
help wise,
helped,
was willing to listen.
It was also willing to listen to Canadians.
New ideas for the order for one Canadian said the order needed a rearrangement
of its hierarchy.
He suggested bringing in new levels under the existing three levels.
The end result of this was 13 ranks of Illuminati members each subdivided within
the original three levels.
The three new overarching levels have the names of the nursery,
the messianic grades,
and the mysteries can also used his influence to change.
Why?
How strong messaging about the church and about religion.
He realized that such a strong stance might be hampering the group's ability to
grow and recruit new and powerful members after the church wielded much power in
Bavaria in the 18th century,
and even the promise that our society with secrets might not be strong enough
assurance for men from powerful families to risk joining.
Why subs listens to you.
Can you get.
And the Illuminati,
they benefited from an organization of just 60.
They grew to 200 by 17,
82,
then the group group to 3000 members by 1784.
The illuminati or Dorsey spread beyond varia membership now included Hungary,
Poland,
and Italy.
But having that many members spread throughout a number of countries made it
harder and harder to keep things quiet,
and if they're very purpose was to infiltrate and influence political thought
and actions,
then of course the upper echelons of society would start to notice them.
In 1794,
that group became a problem.
Then members of the Illuminati were sending correspondence back and forth and
the governments have their eye out for his writings with internal Illuminati
ideas and policies were intercepted in Bavaria.
It's also been thought that this interception was set up by this point wise
helped handsome,
disgruntled members within his ranks.
When we first started the organization,
he told some members that would be a supernatural communication if they achieved
the highest level within the society,
but plenty of people who had achieved this by 17,
84 and there was no supernatural communication to be hat baron can Nigga and why
Sam's.
They also had a major disagreements.
They didn't have the same idea about some of the societies rituals and their
arguments culminated in Canoga leaving the secret society.
The same year he left the Illuminati.
The Bavarian government banned all secret societies.
That was in 1784,
which was the same year that the membership had exploded.
By the next year.
The Bavarian government took it a step further.
They banned the Illuminati specifically as part of the Illuminati banishment.
The government began reading.
The documents have known Illuminati documents started to be published,
and it's this secret society and its membership.
It wasn't so secret anymore.
Public officials became known as members putting that livelihoods and societal
rankings on the line.
The illuminati simply couldn't function with its membership.
Being known throughout all of this society building and government influencing
why sapped had still been working as a professor at the University of English
stocks,
but when the government banned the Illuminati,
he was forced to flee his home and leave behind his job wise,
it wasn't kind to the governments,
to governments of any sorts of not just Bavaria,
so it is not surprising that they were not pleased with his writings.
So just how strongly did he feel about the governments?
Well,
take this quote,
when man lives under government,
he has fallen,
is worth is gone and his nature tarnished when the illuminati were bands from
Bavaria.
Why Sandra was forced to fleet to go to another part of Germany.
That waste helped,
was protected by a sympathetic duke.
Duke Ernest not only provided political protection for Weiss ops,
but he also gave him a pension that's allowed him to live without working.
Even though the Illuminati had been disbanded in various [inaudible],
kept pushing the ideas that had led him to start the secret society in the first
place.
He began rising ultimately publishing for books about the history of the
Illuminati and defending.
It's existence.
The books were intended both to defend himself and to perhaps encourage new
growth for the Illuminati and the province of Gota.
There's one way helped passed away in 1830.
The illuminati had all but disappeared from the world.
It's not easy to operate even as a secret society.
When major world powers,
they simply want you gone.
While the Illuminati may have disappeared,
at least in membership in Europe.
The group by no means disappeared from the world's imagination and conversations
based on today's conspiracy theories and the prevalence of the Illuminati and
pop culture.
It can be argued that why south succeeded in creating a secret society that had
an influence on the world.
Dan Brown's massively popular novels feature the Illuminati in angels and
demons.
Brown pits the Illuminati against the Catholic church in a modern setting.
Throughout the book,
they use churches and artwork to commit atrocities,
relying heavily on coded symbolism benders.
The illuminati trilogy books that claim George Washington was actually replaced
by a member of the Illuminati.
They claim that this imposter actually ran the United States.
People even suggest that the ion,
the American $1 bill is an indication of Illuminati interference and American
governments why stops and the Illuminati are also used in video games and comic
books and even rap songs.
There are regular feature on history channel shows and mysterious shows about
conspiracies from all around the world.
When major events happen,
think that JFK assassination and nine slash 11,
the Illuminati name still gets tossed around as a possible course and there's
even a theory that the modern day Illuminati and now headquartered in Bavaria or
where it was founded,
but right in the heart of the United States.
I was in Washington DC,
not in New York,
not in Los Angeles,
but in Denver,
hidden beneath the airport and the Colorado city is said to be the headquarters
for the modern day incarnation of the most powerful secret society in the world.
Everything from the airports,
runway design to its underground tunnels have been pointed to as evidence for
why it's a perfect site for the societies operation.
It seems that 250 years after we first launched his idea for a secret society is
influenced,
is still felt from pop culture to events of historic magnitude.
The illuminati is still a factor,
at least in terms of people bringing up their name.
Now,
it might not be exactly what he was planning or maybe it was,
do we really know how a secret society operates and has influence,
I mean by south did plan for the Illuminati to operate in the backgrounds after
all,
so I really hope you enjoyed that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put our brand new videos every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday when we put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch something else right now,
stuff from the archive over there on the right and as always,
thank you for watching.